[Music]
the only brownies i ever ate growing up
were these it's the recipe my mom would
make to bring to pta meetings we had it
for dessert at dinner parties like these
brownies are always a hit
hi i'm alexis deboshnick and today i'm
going to show you how to make my one
bowl fudgy brownie recipe from my
upcoming cookbook to the last bite
there's walnuts there's salt it's fudgy
sweet savory it's really my perfect
brownie
first i like to line the pan with
parchment paper just so it's easy to
bring them out of the tray place the
chocolate in a microwave safe bowl and
microwave it in 30 second intervals just
until the chocolate's melted
now that the chocolate's melted you're
going to add the melted butter and use a
hand mixer to be until just combined
now add the sugar combine again
alternatively you can do this in a stand
mixer or even by hand add vanilla
extract and eggs
and once again
be until combined
add kosher salt and flour and just
carefully combine
making sure not to overbeat the batter
these are really fudgy brownies they've
got an incredible texture i had some
walnuts for a bit of crunch and some
flaky sea salt on top so you're really
balancing that sweet savory flavor
profile but if you don't like walnuts or
have an allergy you can use another type
of nut
pour the brownie batter into the pan and
then use a spatula to smooth the top
pop them in the oven and they're going
to bake for 25 minutes
[Music]
i like to top my brownies with some
flaky sea salt but it's really important
that you let them cool for at least 30
minutes
you just lift them out of the pan
away and enjoy
one of the reasons i love these brownies
is that it's all done in one bowl easy
to make easy clean up what could be
better than that
this is just one recipe in my upcoming
cookbook to the last bite it comes out
april 19th and there's over a hundred
recipes many which were inspired by my
childhood like these brownies
[Music]
they're fudgy they're sweet they're
salty
the perfect texture i really hope you
make these brownies
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you